two of apple's best ipad products in
their lineup are getting major redesigns
this year with some breakthrough
features that we haven't seen on an ipad
ever before especially on the m2 ipad
pro which i'm going to talk about now
apple actually gave us a huge hint to
the release date and i'm almost 100 sure
on the release date for at least one of
these ipads because they recently said
that their ipad os 16 software update is
getting delayed and it's not going to
launch until october which is a huge
hint at when we could see those ipads
because i personally believe that those
ipads might launch alongside the ipad os
16 update for one main reason and that
is stage manager which apple has been
working on and i'm thinking that maybe
this delay has to do with the stage
manager feature which is basically the
new multitasking feature that puts
everything together
in this view on your ipad like recently
they just announced that they're
optimizing for instagram and other
iphone apps as well which is a big deal
but this is a huge update that they're
doing so what if it's taking longer than
expected for example steve trout and
smith in ios developer recently said
that he genuinely doesn't think ipad
stage manager is salvageable in its
current form it's layered on tons of
different behaviors that interact in
bizarre inconsistent and unpredictable
ways hidden behind mystery gestures
unmarked tap targets screen regions
hidden destructive actions everywhere
basically he is not happy with how it
works he's saying that it needs a lot
more work on the optimization side from
apple so this could be why apple is
delaying this ipad os 16 update until
october now the reason that's important
is because
mark german actually broke that story
and he said it's getting delayed by
about a month and apple is now targeting
an october release alongside mac os
ventura now that is important because
stage manager is also available on the
mac with mac os ventura so if it's
available on both ipad os and mac os the
new versions maybe apple wants to
release them at the same time which is
the reason for that delay which will be
in october and then going even deeper
stage manager is only available for m1
ipads which means that the new m2 ipad
pro that we're expecting in the fall is
also going to support stage manager so
what if that could be the release date
of the m2 ipad pro sometime in october
when apple says ipad os 16 should be
released alongside mac os ventura so
that's basically the biggest hint we
have of the m2 ipad pro coming at an
apple october event just like joe
resignal from mac rumors is saying we
could get the m2 ipad pro we could get
the new 10th gen ipad which i'm going to
talk about and ipad with 16 at the same
time however just like joe says right
here there is a chance that the 10gen
ipad could get a quick announcement
during the september event instead and
maybe it ships in september without the
new ipad with 16 or maybe they delay the
launch until october and release
everything at once i'm not sure but
that's also a possibility and now
getting into the actual design of the
next entry level 10 generation ipad we
had a major leak from my smart price
which actually has been correct in the
past showing off of course the new flat
sided redesign which is a huge deal now
getting into the actual renders right
here we can take a look and see some
huge differences first of all you have
the usbc port finally which means all of
apple's ipads will now be switching to
usb type-c which is a big deal and then
of course we have those flat sides we
have the speaker grilles on the bottom
and right here this is interesting
because they're changing up the camera
bump with a microphone right here and a
camera it's just a little different
design but you can see that the display
is not getting the same update redesign
that it did with apple's other ipads
like the ipad pro the air and the mini
those all got edge to edge displays with
even bezels all around and they got rid
of the home button but this one keeps
the home button as you can see and it
keeps the square display design which is
a bit unfortunate now here we can see
that you also have the speaker grilles
on the top with a regular power button
but
the headphone jack is gone so apple is
finally scrapping it there will be no
more ipads with the headphone jack which
makes sense because apple is going to be
selling different accessories to replace
that so like air pods or even home pod
speakers if you're at home and just to
prove to you guys that it's not going to
be that bad renders by shy lash just
created some new renders of the 2022
ipad and looking at this renders i mean
that looks awesome look at that looks
really clean you got this metal bump
design
of course you have the square display
which is unfortunate but looking at this
it still looks great look at that you
got the camera bump sticking out nice
clean design i personally think this is
totally fine for the budget ipad and i
do believe that because of usbc and the
flat sides they are going to raise the
price from the current 329 to maybe as
high as 399
or maybe 350 around there so it's gonna
be more expensive this time around but
it makes sense why now i know a lot of
people are complaining about this front
panel design with the home button the
uneven big bezels the square display but
if you think about it it actually makes
sense for apple because if they made
this edge to edge looking just like the
other ipads you wouldn't be able to tell
that this is different compared to the
ipad air other than the size difference
so you could just buy this thing pretend
you have an ipad air most people won't
know but apple wants to make sure that
if you're spending the extra money it
looks better than the budget model they
always want the budget model to look
cheap and old in comparison to their
more expensive ipads which is why i
think they went with this design and on
top of that of course this square
display is a lot cheaper to manufacture
compared to the other displays that are
edge to edge with the rounded corners
because they actually physically cut the
pixels on those displays so it is more
expensive but i am hoping for a
laminated display and then another nice
thing for apple is that because the usb
type-c port is here and it's replacing
the lightning port it is no longer going
to support the apple pencil first
generation which means that people can't
reuse their same apple pencil they have
to buy the new one so apple is making
more money with this move and now of
course we also have the m2 ipad pro
which is gonna have a pretty big
redesign now recently in june mark
german did say that it's gonna debut in
either september or october and i think
it makes total sense to be october
because apple is delaying ipad os 16
until october so that's almost
guaranteed right now it's gotta be in
october during an apple event for sure
but the big change is that we're getting
wireless charging debuting on this new
redesigned ipad pro which is a
breakthrough feature that we've never
had on an ipad because it's always been
metal and we never had anything to use
with mac safe and it's gonna eventually
reverse wireless charge your other
magsafe devices which means you could
have your ipad and then you can plop on
your airpods right on the back and max
safe charge them or in the future maybe
with the series 8 pro apple watch with
max safe you can plop that on their
charge it maybe even your iphone with a
mac save case and i do believe that the
new magic keyboard could get a
redesigned with mag safe support built
into the actual keyboard case itself so
that is going to be amazing now as far
as the performance we already know how
the m2 chip performs in the m2 macbook
air and the macbook pro and we do know
that the cpu now takes 36 percent more
power to basically give us around 13 to
15 cpu improvement and multi-core so it
does use a lot more power which means
that within the ipad pro chassis there
is a good chance that the m2 chip is
going to be throttled down and perform
worse than it does in the m2 macbook so
keep that in mind but i also think that
there's a chance that apple to save
money could literally grab the logic
board from the inside of the m2 macbook
air and put the exact same logic board
complete with everything into the m2
ipad pro which is going gonna make it a
lot cheaper to manufacture so i feel
like they're gonna do that but i can't
confirm that just yet all i know is that
these two ipads are getting some major
redesigns so this is gonna be a really
good year to buy an ipad so if you're
thinking about buying one just hold off
and wait until those two come in october
so hopefully you enjoyed this video and
if it was helpful click the circle above
to subscribe definitely check out one of
those two videos right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]